Point your career to be great or do you
want to stay true to yourself I could do
it how I want to do it which is maybe
emotional maybe talking about certain
things is slower there's more melodic
songs or you can make it the way that
you know it'll go up which is stack it
with features Up Tempo beats don't get
too personal just make it a fun album
make it light it's almost like do you
want your career to be great or do you
want to stay true to yourself bro that's
why the internet [__] is the greatest
thing of all time because the answer is
both whatever the [__] pumping your
heart at that moment like people don't
think about it that heavy this is your
baby so you're looking at it that way
out these doors they're just going song
by song anyway they are like the
ideology that you're baking in your head
around this is going to be this kind of
project people talking projects and
albums and the consumer doesn't give a
[__] you need to do you period and a
story and what's funny about what I'm
saying is I actually think that's
Freedom not the reverse I don't I get it
because that's how it's cycling through
your head right now here's the good news
I didn't need it that are 23.